paloma david luge herzlich willkommen
wie heute meine damen und herren zu
einem neuen video auf meinem kanal ihr
seht schon ich sitze hier wieder nicht
alleine sondern nehmen
die ganz cool source deutschland und wir
nehmen heute zusammen mal wieder ein
video auf und verrät es bereits im titel
sandra spielt heute zum ersten mal
minecraft bevor wir uns gleich in das
spiel rein stürzen sondern erst einmal
eine frage an dich hast du schon beim
einkauf gespielt
mein gott gespielt noch nie noch nie
weißt du was ist ein wahrhaft den wusste
dass moment lücken wie vor dass ihr
durch nicht so waren richtig jetzt auf
einzelspieler und liege erst mal auf
neue welt erstellen dass meine welt ja
dass deine welt die auf die es jetzt
geht es noch nicht fertig sandra also
das ist seine welt
beweg dich martina ertl spiels minecraft
mit der maus und der tastatur also du
kannst so hüpft man nehme da läuft man
hier mit wer als diw ist sie das ist ja
genau jetzt mittelfinger auf wäre genau
das fordert hiermit kannst du nicht so
oben gucken und das ist das wasser
genauer trinkst du gerade
sie essen wie wie kann ich danach und
tauchen shift wo ist denn der tüv da ja
wir haben dann musst du erstmal
durchschnaufen
und was macht ihr spaß hat mir spaß
gemacht
das macht mir immer noch spaß ich
vermute das ist ein cooles spielt muss
halt überlegen mannschaft es ist halt so
jeder der das spiel gespielt hat eine
eigene welt jeder die keiner nehmen die
gleiche welt so kannst du die ganze
palette gedroht hatten mit einem daumen
sandra genau und jetzt mit den drei
fingern machst du denn hier genau da
genau
man kann es war schlimm und da kannst du
die hand an die maus
genau das ist die steuerung die man oder
die hand position über die ganze zeit
haben sollte
du kannst der taste wieder loslassen
jetzt muss wieder drücken damit so hoch
springen und dabei webt damit nun auf
erst nach vorne springt er sehr gut du
wirst alt du bist auf eine einsame insel
du hast kein essen glaube ich darum
einen bremer stehen zeitlich den
verstimmungen geht es ja nicht um wenn
nicht dann war das spiel gar kein spaß
[Musik]
die wahrheit kann und so war da sich das
sind fische h was für wahrheit ist der
schwund sehen fischer welt sehen war
dahin ist noch nicht sicher aber da mal
hin schwimmen und hatte schon entfernt
weiß nicht ob ich die kondition darf ja
aber drei wochen später luca wie lange
dauert das denn noch kann es kann dann
kann man sich im sprint machten im
sprint übers wasser ja so wie jesus
damals jesus vom als das meer hoch ging
genau der eine frage was war war aber
viel spaß wenn ich jetzt einfach nur weh
es drücke leertaste leute hier 50
stunden davor chillen alter ja das frage
ich mich tatsächlich auch an minecraft
geht's aber auf jeden fall darum dass
jeder der in das spiel rein geht eine
eigene web hat das heißt keine maps
sieht genauso aus wie der andere und
deine mäppchen sie dann ganz schön
beschissen aus so langweilig alter du
kannst einfach weh und leertaste
gedrückt halten die ganze zeit dann
läuft du die ganze zeit genau also
leertaste nicht nur wenn im wasser ist
das ziel des spiels ist auf jeden fall
dass du das spiel mehr oder weniger
durch spielst der vater kann ich deine
waadtländer will levels er will
zusätzlich unbedingt aber es gibt einen
ort der heißt
ja das ent und dadurch viel und wenig da
da da das ja das ist das dauert zu lang
das zu erklären auf jeden fall ist quasi
das ziel des spiels dass du in diese
maßnahme in der scheiße wo ist denn das
zu essen
du kannst mal fische töten theoretisch
auf jeden fall ist das ziel des spiels
was man irgendwie auch ein mcdonalds
aufbauen
ja ich hab ich habe etwas gefunden luca
was denn das da da waren das die insel
oder was das ist ein tintenfisch ein
tintenfisch ist keine
umweltverschmutzung beknackten den
frisch gesehen doch die fresse kommen
doch zu mir ich wo er habe kein leben ja
auf jeden fall um aufs thema
zurückzukommen das ziel des spiels ist
immer noch ein tintenfisch sandra und
dann kannst du ihn gleich schlagen wenn
du näher dran bist du kannst jetzt nicht
auf 20 geschlagen genau wie ein bisschen
zurück genau wissen wieder genau und
jetzt gleich jeden moment kannst du den
tinten verschlagen weil du bist dann in
der reichweite kopf
man hat ja kein leben mehr hab ich das
spiel verloren ja jetzt wird automatisch
installiert
du kannst jetzt ganz einfach auf
wiederbeleben klicken hier zack und dann
bist du wieder da wo du vorhin
hergekommen bist aber sandra um die das
ganze spielprinzip noch mal ganz kurz zu
erklären das ziel des spiels ist es dass
du diesen ort namens entkommt und da
fliegt dann ein drache rum der ender
dragon und demos zu töten und das ist
quasi jetzt soll die stelle ist taste
mit der links taste ja das ist dass
jedes spiels und bis dahin kann zu
passiven machen was du willst also kann
es theoretisch sagen du willst jetzt
diese sand blog abbauen und geht auch ja
du kannst die ganze welt verändern und
jetzt hast du quasi den song blog hier
unten drin hier das ist ein inventar
wir sind allerdings dass hier bist du
bringst du ich sehr voll scheiße aus
besser als ein recht auf jeden fall
kannst du hier mit der linken maustaste
wände gedrückt hält kannst du dinge halt
einfach abbauen wenn du jetzt natürlich
sind schlägst du die ganze zeit wenn du
das drückt aber dem steaks quasi den
block kaputt und die blogger nehmen mit
der rechten maustaste wieder irgendwie
hinsetzen und dann können wir
beispielsweise sonnenring bauen
das ist eine frage und hat bringt mir
die waage bringt mir dieser turm jetzt
das wichtigste für dich jetzt hier
allerdings erst mal ist dass du dir holz
holst weil aus holz kannst du dir
stöcker bauen und aufstockern kannst du
dir sachen machen wie eine spitzhacke
oder ein schwert und damit kannst du
dich dann gegen gegner verteidigen also
leute würden wegen rückhalt und immer
hüpfen wenn sie hüpfen müssen soll
dadurch die ganze zeit weh und lehrt
haben in der ganzen zeit bei uns ab das
anders du hast dein erstes stück holz
banken jetzt kann seiner rechtsweg
drücken irgendwo jedoch direkt da ja ich
möchte aber noch mehr holz er als
gedrückthalten gedrückt halten und dann
hast du deinen neue des tages stolz und
packen jetzt übereinander
ich finde man hat hier so einen leichten
fehler drin wie viel das spiel gefällt
mir gar nicht
jetzt hab ich dir aber ich wusste jetzt
mal holz als übereinander oder wie ja
auch ein bisschen mehr holz eben das wir
gefühl irgendwie doch noch ist gar nicht
alles sascha guck mal nach links kurz
nach rechts wieder da wo die sonne ist
die sonne geht nämlich jetzt unter weiß
was das heißt nein es wird nacht weiß
was das heißt nein es wird dunkel und
weißt du was passiert wenn es dunkel
wird dann kommen monster
ich habe keine waffe da jetzt gedrückt
halten auf dem baumstamm und da gedrückt
halten genau dann kriegen sie das zweite
stück holz und brauchst dann auch noch
ein drittes stück holz und damit kann
man schon mal die ersten sachen machen
also denen da oben jetzt hast du drei
häufig und jetzt drückst du einmal
jetzt nimmst du dein holz jetzt gehst du
da oben hin auf das viererfeld jetzt
genauso praxis da rein drückt noch mal
und jetzt drückt sie bereits drei mal
drauf noch mal und jetzt packst du davon
alle vier voll
ich mach das mal
packen wir jetzt das hier so rein und
das hier ist das crafting rezept für ein
schwert und jetzt habe ich denke das ist
etwas was reißen die monster luca sind
die monster sandra dass das ist ein
unterwasser licht genauso wie das da
hinten und das und das frau simons dass
das ist ich habe das ganze spiel jetzt
mal ein bisschen heller eingestellt also
dass es mit dem chef sagen ja
guckt man nach vorne da wird jetzt leute
ich hab das ganze ein bisschen heller
eingestellt damit ihr zumindest ein
bisschen was sehen können zu hause
sammer wir sind jetzt auf dieser welt
und wer sdw ersten leertaste immer
gedrückter alt warum sind sie so
anstrengend weil du neben mir sitzt du
machst mich nervös
[Gelächter]
du hast dich manchmal an wie so ein
bösewicht der anschauen von anderen
seite ja es ist wie sollst du denn
schlafen sommer das klingt schon dafür
und gehe schlafen die sonne den da zieht
business rule the world die uhr kann man
jetzt vom wasser das vom meer das da
rein packten dann haben wir swimmingpool
in welchen whirlpools warst du denn
bisher in deinem leben halt aber dass
sie das ist einfach nur eingegrabene
stück scheiße anscheinend ist es in
minecraft jetzt so dass die irgendwie
unter wasser viel mehr hinzugefügt haben
das sieht man auch hier mit diesen
ganzen sträuchern wahrscheinlich jeder
der länger schon minecraft spielt ein
paar monate der wird mir jetzt sagen
dass da schon länger der fall
durch die hitze wird das bedeutet diese
rolle hat mal wege drückt sich und genau
das geschafft alter kommen dann leben
sandra was sonst noch alles herzlich
das wichtigste ist eigentlich in
minecraft dass man nachts übernachtet
hat
wie bin ich ja jetzt gestorben bist
irgendwo punktestand neun minuten
was ist an der stelle würde ich auf
jeden fall das heutige video als auch
werden beide damen und herren ich halts
ehrlich gesagt nicht damit die aus hier
was nimmst du dir auf jeden fall dass
zum heutigen video zu gast was sagen
danke dass ich mit dir hier minecraft
spielen durfte dass die das spiel zeigen
und erklären durfte wie hat es dir denn
gefallen auf einer skala von 7 bis b ok
vorhin als er nicht genutzt hast du nur
wsd genutzt aber nutzen wir jetzt genau
wenn euch das heutige die auf jeden fall
gefallen hat das unbedingt einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da sandra hat
jetzt auch einen youtube-kanal erzählt
sandra und es ist schon der erste block
online genau
sandra hat auch im youtube-kanal erzählt
wie sandra heißt die dame ist auch und
in der beschreibung von den könnt ihr
gern mal vorbeischauen außerdem ist
soeben eine neue folge unseres podcasts
und ein regal geht und so
in der folge haben wir geredet über
politik genau wenn ihr euch anhören
wollt dann ist dazu auch einlegen und in
der video beschreibung schreibt uns gern
die kommentare falls sie einen zweiten
dritten teil sandra luca minecraft haben
wollt oder nicht
ich hoffe nicht dass das wahr ist echt
anstrengend ich habe auch nicht und ich
würde sagen wir verabschieden uns an
dieser stelle gott besonders konnte
[Musik]